bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france troisième jour du
procès des attentats de janvier 2015
aujourd'hui cette journée elle est
consacrée au profil des accusés
jusqu'ici quel bilan vous fait écouter
c'est très ironique justement d'ouvrir
le journal sur un discours du président
de la république qui évoque la laïcité
les ingérences étrangères
sans nommer toutefois l'islam mais tout
le monde a bien compris que c'est de
cela dont il s'agit c'est et de le faire
justement cette période un procès qui
s'inscrit dans un contexte particulier
alors il faut savoir que depuis peu de
temps comme vous le savez le garde des
sceaux c'est eric dupond moretti qui est
de surcroît au delà de l'indépendance
des magistrats
le chef de la magistrature debout c'est
à dire du ministère public et du parquet
et donc eric dupond moretti a été
l'avocat d'abdelkader meira celui qui a
fait à acquitter appel qu'à des remera
en première instance
donc ça a été un choc énorme pour la
communauté juive et dans ce procès il
est question des auteurs et des victimes
de l'attentât de l'hyper cacher et donc
le garde des sceaux un tout autre rôle à
assumer
je pense donc les réquisitions du
parquet seront sans aucune pitié
extrêmement sévère à l'encontre des
accusés mais il faut toutefois
reconnaître que dans ce procès le
comment dire les principaux auteurs des
attentats sont morts donc vous parliez
des frères belhocine edel mediène la
probabilité de les voire emprisonner un
jour est extrêmement faible puisque tous
les services étrangers et les services
français avancent l'hypothèse de leur
décès maintenant écouter etc il s'agit
simplement peut-être d'aider les
familles dans un processus psychologique
de deuil est également
2 comment dire de fermer une porte le
plan juridique c'est à dire dans
l'hypothèse extrêmement peu probable où
l'un de ses auteurs de ses complices
referait surface en france ou à
l'étranger de pouvoir l'emprisonner
immédiatement mais tout le monde sait au
delà du soulagement de la libération de
la parole et de la volonté de comprendre
que ça n'arrivera jamais en fait voilà
c'est un procès pour la forme
je pense qu'on en apprendra beaucoup
plus dans les procès qui vont suivre
c'est à dire en l'occurrence celui de
l'attentât du thalys celui de l'attentât
manqué de l'église de villejuif et celui
des attentats du 13 novembre
mais concernant charlie hebdo on sait
très bien que même si militairement
effectivement nous avons vaincu les
terroristes parce qu'ils ont été
neutralisés au moment des attentats que
politiquement ils ont gagné parce qu'ils
ont ils ont décidé de leur important
tout de même ce procès se tienne oui
parce que comme je vous le disais au
plan psychologique pour les familles des
victimes
c'est important c'est à dire qui et de
volonté de comprendre on va prendre
connaissance de certains éléments
déclassifiés d'ailleurs on apprend par
vos confrères de médiapart que peut-être
que la dgs y aurait suivi les frères
couach ya un parce que nous parle de
rapports d' approche au cours desquelles
des sources auraient approché les 3
charasse alors que depuis cinq ans on
nous raconte que justement les
surveillances avaient abandonné donc on
voit bien que si finalement ce procès
c'est un petit peu une blanchisseuse de
pour nous laisser penser que les
services de l'état ont bien agi et
qu'ils avaient fait leur maximum
mais on se rend bien compte que
finalement il ya quand même des zones
d'ombré il va falloir aller au delà
justement des éléments justement puisque
vous parlez des zones d'ombré trois
accusés mentale appel dont hayat
boumédiène à la campagne d'amis
coulibaly selon certaines rumeurs elle
serait toujours en fuite
comment vous expliquez vous que l'on ait
perdu sa trace
écoutez c'est là c'est avant tout une
négligence s'est vu une faille en fait
dans le système administratif français
qui a été exploitée par les terreaux et
c'est parce que ce sont loin d'être des
imbéciles vocalises étaient tous fichés
s c'est à dire que ce soit les frères
belhoucine wyatt boumédiène et qui
serait pas pu quitter l'aéroport d'orly
ou de roissy le sens être signalés dont
qu'ils ont pris ils ont profité de
l'ouverture des frontières à l'intérieur
de l'espace schengen pour se rendre à
madrid et pour fuir à partir de
l'espagne comme le fichage français n'a
pas lieu en espagne a ciblé bon bah ils
sont partis en toute tranquillité
donc après selon certaines rumeurs
écoutez c'est une revenante de syrie qui
essayent de négocier une forme d'
amnistie ou d'indulgence avec la justice
française et les services de police de
qu'elle donne met à disposition des
services de police sans un sens sans
fournir aucune preuve une voilà un
élément qui laisserait penser quasi
immédiate serait encore en vie qui à
laquelle aurait fui un camp
d'emprisonnement comme par hasard bien
entendu moi écouter gg mais de forts
doutes quant à l'hypothèse qui a été
avancé maintenant écouter on verra bien
mais moi je pense que c'est un procès
pour la forme on aura sans doute une
condamnation par contumace et bon voilà
ça aidera les familles dans l'autre dans
le processus de deuil
mais on sait très bien que finalement
justice a déjà été faite le jour où les
terroristes ont été tués mais que le
rapport malheureusement de force n'est
pas en notre faveur puisque amedi
coulibaly a quand même tué une policière
des victimes innocentes à l'hyper cacher
donc
voilà dix ans derrière son média nous
dit qu'elle risque le risque total
justement parce que vous remettez les
hypothèses
je pense sans trop m'avancer qu'elle
sera condamné à la réclusion criminelle
à perpétuité
et que finalement voilà c'est cette
condamnation sera assorti d'un mandat
d'arrêt international et que ce tout
cela sera fait dans l'hypothèse où elle
referait surface un jour quelque part
qu'elles seraient localisés en france ou
à l'étranger
mais comme je vous le dis sans trop coup
sans trop m'avancer mais sans trop me
tromper non plus je pense que ce jour
n'arrivera jamais sonné plus finalement
dans l'ère du symbolique et de la
compréhension des événements
tout simplement voilà mes mais comme je
vous le disais leur simple absence
finalement est criante
puisque ça ça dénote ça nous donne bien
le fait qu'on l'ait laissé partir qu'on
ait laissé quitter le territoire et bon
concernant les frères belhocine on sait
très bien qu'ils sont décédées de longue
date et ça a été admis par la cia par la
dgse par la dgs y écouter si on veut
effectivement faire le procès de
personne décédée si ça peut profiter aux
familles des victimes moi je suis pas
contre mais j'aurais préféré que cela
n'arrive jamais et que les services de
renseignement puissent empêcher
justement ces actes terroristes d'avoir
lieu au moment où ils ont été perpétrés
puisqu'on avait largement les moyens
comme le démontre l'enquète que vous
avez diffusé hier
merci à vous norme ias noir je rappelle
que cette déléguée générale du syndicat
végépolys